foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror my book review Series so Elias
witherow uh hopefully I'm pronouncing
that uh name right uh he wrote a book
called the black Farm
and this was published uh by Thought
Catalog back in 2017. this book was
actually recommended to me uh by a
friend during a live stream like on the
chat and when I kind of looked a little
bit into it it seemed to have had a lot
of Buzz surrounding it like when it came
out judging by just the general reviews
and there were a lot of people on like
Goodreads and Reddit and stuff like that
that were recommending it so I thought
that I would give it a shot now as is my
usual habit I didn't read a synopsis of
the book or any of the reviews prior to
diving into it I didn't look up anything
in particular about the author I was
just you know it was recommended to me
so I wrote it down and eventually like I
bought the ebook and read it now I'll
say right from the outset this would
probably be classified as extreme horror
it's not it's not the worst thing that
I've ever read like in that regard but
it is pretty graphic it's pretty Grim a
pretty soul-crushing so if you're not
really into reading very explicitly
detailed description of suicide rape
torture dismemberment and cannibalism
and if you can't really stomach you know
gallons of stinking vomit then maybe you
might want to give this one a pass as I
said it's not the most extreme horror
I've ever read by a long stretch most of
it didn't even phase me which I don't
that's probably not a good thing because
that probably means I've gotten like way
too jaded in my old age but it's still
like pretty depressing and pretty gross
so you know if that's not your cup of
ipicac or whatever then probably stay
far away from this one because it's kind
of [ __ ] up I will also admit that
um while I actually found this book to
be a very quick like action-packed read
that had some really really imaginative
ideas behind it and did actually like
compel me to keep reading it I was kind
of like eager to see what in the hell
was gonna happen next like what was the
outcome of all this was going to be I
did have some problems with it
um so I think overall I was a little bit
ambivalent lent about the whole
experience of reading this book like I
liked it but I feel like I didn't like
it maybe as much as some other people
did and I'll kind of like try to get
into why that is like later on so the
black Farm is told from the first person
perspective of a young man named Nick
who has a girlfriend named Jess now the
couple has endured like a series of like
really bad tragedies like over the
previous year there's been like a couple
of their family members have died like
one of their family members like has
terminal cancer Nick loses his job they
get an eviction notice because you know
they don't have enough money to pay the
rent and worst of all uh Jess actually
suffers a miscarriage of a baby that she
very very much wanted
so this final loss was kind of like the
straw that broke the camel's back and
Jess who comes across as she's like a
very sweet compassionate uh you know
woman she really just can't take it
anymore she doesn't really understand
why the world has suddenly seemed so
like cruel and pitiless toward her like
with all of these horrible things just
mounting on her like at the same time so
she decides that she's going to end her
own life and Nick who can't really
imagine having any life without her uh
basically vows that they will go out
together
so they do they uh swallow a bunch of
sleeping pills you know just in their
house and their couch like they've
agreed to do this because they just
can't go on anymore because of all the
tragedies in their life like world has
just turned to [ __ ] on them but as it
turns out uh their death is really only
the beginning of a horrible horrible
unimaginable nightmare so only a few
pages into the book Nick basically
awakens in just like a world of pain
he's being dragged across the ground
like by a chain or something by what
appears to be like a huge disfigured man
of some kind he's taken into this
building and chained up in like a
concrete cell and then like a normal
kind of looking dude whose name is Danny
like comes in and gives him like a
little bit of scuttlebutt about what
exactly is going on here so he tells
Nick that when you commit suicide you
end up in this place which is called the
black Farm it's kind of something like I
guess like a purgatorial type of
dimension in a sense uh it's neither
Heaven Nor Hell it was apparently
created by some kind of demigod or like
some kind of similar being known only as
the pig who was actually like allowed to
kind of fashion the place to his liking
like within reason or within certain
parameters since apparently neither God
nor the devil could decide on what to do
with the people that they have deemed
suicidals so the pig has created a place
that's sort of like the world we know
but it's like really twisted in a bunch
of ways like the black Farm apparently
like exists on this island and it's
surrounded by this massive seemingly
Endless Ocean that's patrolled by these
like massive like gargantuan Monsters uh
there is a sun but it's like broken like
it's almost like a broken egg or
something like that and it like leaks
kind of like black poison like into the
ocean it's always raining like steadily
drizzling rain all the time there's like
no day or night there's like a forest
and there's like mount mountains and
various dwellings of different kinds but
everything there is just like gray and
hopeless and horrible and it's just kind
of like a never-ending Litany of just
pain and misery like all the time now
aside from all the human suicidals who
are kind of roaming through this
desolate hellscape there are also these
other kind of monstrous beings that are
called the pig born and you know true to
their name they're kind of like The
malformed Offspring of the pig and their
whole thing is to just brutally torture
anyone in like horrible horrible ways
like whenever they come across somebody
now even though the humans that are
trapped on the black Farm are
technically like already dead from our
standpoint they can still feel pain and
suffer just like a living human being
would so they've essentially they're
still like the same as a human even
though they're like already dead
um and also when they die on the farm
because you can die like when you're uh
in on the black Farm but they then they
get like reborn into it it like with
their previous wounds healed up but they
kind of like regenerate like in a
different part of the farm than before
so they essentially have to like start
over it's kind of like a video game
character uh that you're kind of like
all healed up but now you're gonna get
like tormented Anew and now you don't
know where you are and like any progress
you made before is like erased so after
Nick endures just horrific tortures and
various indignities he just begins to
get angrier and angrier and begins to
get like even more determined to find
Jess and get them both the hell out of
this place even though he doesn't really
even know if that's possible like he
doesn't even know if that's a thing that
you can do the only way that you can
leave the farm or so he's led to believe
is by doing something called feeding the
pig which will either send you like
straight to Hell Which is far far worse
than the farm which is like really
really hard to imagine because the farm
is like pretty bad or
um it might like send you back to your
old life like for another go you know
what I mean but there's no way of
knowing like prior to you have to like
make the decision yeah I'm gonna go feed
the pig but you don't know like what the
outcome is going to be so you could end
up in like an even worse place than you
were before
um but a lot of people will do that just
for the opportunity hey maybe I'll be
able to go back to my life and like fix
what I [ __ ] up or whatever but you
don't know how it's gonna come out so
the bulk of the story is basically Nick
fighting his way through the farm and
trying to find Jess and then trying to
figure out like a way to escape so along
the way all manner of ghastly horrible
things happen to him and some and also
to some of the other humans that he
meets during his journey and as the book
goes on it just kind of gets Bleaker and
Bleaker and you kind of start to wonder
if there really is any way for anyone to
escape from this this continuous Despair
and violence and [ __ ] like that that's
going on in this world now as I
mentioned the World building and this is
quite good I mean I could really like
picture the appearance of what this
place looked like and and I also thought
that I had a really good handle on kind
of like the rules of the place and what
the stakes were like for the characters
um you know the disgusting bits of which
there are many are also very vividly
written uh you know which may be a good
or bad thing depending on your point of
view I guess uh the very idea of the
black Farm in fact was a really
intriguing concept I mean this place
that's you know essentially the product
of indifferent and maybe like indecisive
deities who don't seem to care all that
much about human suffering so in that
sense this is a very almost kind of like
a nihilistic book I guess because it
leans really hard into the notion that
the worst thing imaginable isn't like a
universe that's just completely devoid
of meaning or completely indifferent but
a universe that seems to be actively run
by gods who don't really give a squirt
of piss about us and sometimes actively
enjoy like watching us writhen Agony
just for their own sick immune Amusement
but I think the thing that maybe
lessened my experience of the story
somewhat was the character development
um and specifically I think like the
difficulty I had in suspending my
disbelief in regards to the characters
like Nick who's our main protagonist
we're seeing everything from his point
of view isn't presented as anyone
special really uh and most of the time
is like pretty unlikable so I had a kind
of a hard time getting on board with the
idea that you know that over all the
Millennia that the black Farm has
presumably existed that he would be the
only one to fight back to the extent
that he did and by the same token like
as an extension of that like sometimes
things seemed just a little too easy for
him like in spite of all the horrors
that he endured like I'm not saying that
he didn't have bad [ __ ] happened to him
because he did but some things were just
like a little too easy like he just
happened to find a weapon for example or
his enemies weren't really like smart
enough or strong enough to like fight
back against him or realize when he was
fooling them or something like that this
might have
big aided somewhat if we had maybe
gotten to know Nick before he was
ejected into the black Farm like if we
knew that he had something about his
past or his psychological makeup that
went some way toward explaining like his
particular skills you know in other
words but we don't get that like the
story begins with him and just
committing suicide and then like you
know literally two or three pages in
like we're on the black Farm or Off to
the Races now we do learn more about
Nick's kind of like inner life his inner
thoughts his weaknesses as we go along
but I felt like
I didn't really know him like as a
person and another thing too was that I
thought the transformation that he went
through like from this beaten terrified
man who you know has had his whole like
uh experience of the world like upended
like he ends up in this place after he
commits suicide and then he's being like
horribly brutally tortured and
everything like that so he starts out as
like a very beaten terrified man as you
would but then it seems like
he he kind of like trans transforms into
this kind of one-liner spouting badass
um and I kind of thought the whole
transformation was very abrupt it kind
of read a little bit like an adolescent
power fantasy kind of like you know I've
talked about a couple of like Richard
Layman books before how a lot of his
books while they're really fun but they
come across like they were written by an
adolescent boy like a little bit this
one kind of comes across like that a
little bit as well like in Nick's
character like not all the time and it's
not as egregious as Richard Layman's
kind of stuff is but I got that kind of
similar vibe from Nick's character I was
also kind of thinking or hoping that
more would be done with Nick's kind of
growing Fury against this place which
understandable and I guess too like the
steady abatement of his empathy toward
others as he was like battling his way
through the farm like I for example like
I suspected at one point that he was
basically going to become like the
monsters that he fought and maybe
realize is that he liked the farm
because it was like he could do whatever
he wanted like without consequence but
nothing really came of all his kind of
like conflicted feelings about all the
Savage things that he had to do like in
order to survive and in order to find
Jess now I will note in the interest of
fairness that there is a sequel to this
book which is called return to the black
farm and it came out in 2019. so maybe
like the seeds planted in you know in
that regard the seeds planted in this
book like maybe come to fruition in that
one but I haven't read it so I can't be
sure so I don't really want to go too
far in that direction but you know
because maybe it is addressed in the in
the book like all the kind of seeds that
were planted in this one about his
morality like or his um kind of empathy
toward others like disintegrating and I
have to say too that sadly the character
of Jess is not fleshed out at all I mean
she's basically just a cipher she's an
object to motivate Nick into bucking the
system at the farm and you know fighting
the whole wretched place she doesn't
really ever seem to make any effort to
save her self she's very Damsel in
Distress she's another thing too is
she's almost like impossibly pure and
forgiving and supportive
um even after Nick makes some pretty
like [ __ ] up confessions like to her
like about prior to them dying
um another woman that he meets at the
farm Megan serves pretty much the same
purpose she's just kind of there to
suffer and thus outrage Nick into acting
you know what I mean uh it's not a great
look but I mean to be fair to the story
Nick is you know in all fairness like
presented as something of a selfish
character which is what you know one of
his big weaknesses so I mean he's not
portrayed as like that bad otherwise
like he seems like an okay guy as far as
that goes but like I said he's not real
fleshed out but the fact that he's kind
of like realizes his selfishness like
before the death and everything like
that maybe we're just seeing everything
through his perceptions and maybe that's
how he views his girlfriend and the
women that he meets in the black Farm
like they're basically like nothing but
props to either like support or motivate
his own efforts like toward whatever
goal he's going for so
so grotesquely entertaining right it's
not fun because it's kind of [ __ ] up
and Grim but it's still like real
compelling and like action-packed and
everything it's a definitely a page
Turner that's for sure uh and the
premise I love the premise of it um it
had like really detailed Gore and like
General sense of [ __ ] up in this and
you know the World building very
imaginative like the set piece is very
imaginative I really really liked all
that but you know the main character
wasn't really all that well delineated
he came across like a little bit Edge
lordy gonna say uh and the other
characters were basically just there as
kind of like cardboard cutouts to either
help or hinder him like on his quest now
the exploration into Nick's like
deteriorating morality was really
interesting and I would have liked to
have seen that play into the story more
uh as I said maybe it does in the sequel
I'm not entirely sure because I haven't
read it yet I'd also like to have had
more time with Nick and Jess like before
they died so that I could maybe get a
better handle on their personalities and
the specifics of their relationship like
so it would be clearer like what made
their love so transcendentally special
that it spurred Nick to this vast Act of
rebellion that apparently no one on the
farm had ever attempted before even
though it's existed since the beginning
of humans evidently I'm gonna say too
just a minor nitpick but the book could
have maybe used like one more pass
through an editor uh there was a kind of
a smattering of grammatical errors and a
couple examples of like incorrect word
usage but you know it wasn't as bad as
other books I've read so I don't want to
harp on that too much now I will say a
lot of people because I did read some
reviews of this like after I had
finished it a lot of people really do
seem to dig this book a lot um I dug it
too just maybe not as much as some other
people did if you're really into extreme
horror and are kind of in the mood for
something that's kind of like depraved
and sort of like existentially harsh and
kind of depressing then you know give it
a whirl a lot of people like I said did
really really seem to love it um and I'd
actually be interested to read the
sequel because you know the World
building is really interesting and I
really like the concept of this place
and I kind of the way it ended I kind of
want to see where it's going to go on
from there and I'm also curious to see
if any of the issues that I had with the
book are dealt with like this stuff
about like I said about Nick having to
do all this [ __ ] up [ __ ] and maybe
feeling conflicted about it because I
think he started to like enjoy being in
a place without consequences and he
could do whatever he wanted so I kind of
wanted to see that like explored a
little bit more and maybe it is in the
sequel not really sure so if you've read
the sequel or you know that it's like
worth reading or it does kind of explore
that then let me know because I'd be
interested to read it and then maybe I
can review it again like in the future
so that'll do it for this tomes of
Terror I'll see you guys again on the
next one bye